These numbers are actually really important. They can represent a fraction. They
can represent a parts of a whole. So, for example, for the circle I have 3 parts
out of 8 or 3 8ths. The three represents my numerator, it's how many parts I
have. The eight represents my denominator, it's how many pieces or parts are in
the whole figure. Fractions don't always have to refer to shapes, they can refer
to other things, and we'll look at this later in the course. But for now, we're
just going to focus on these images and shapes. So 3 8ths is a fraction for this
circle, I want to you find the fraction for these others. You can enter your
answer in these boxes. 3 8ths can also be written as 3 slash 8. It's another way
of writing a fraction. That's how you should type it in when you type it into
these boxes.